[Music]
all right ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to your favorite podcast
[Music]
[Music]
so make sure you hold it away because i
got it all too hot so whatever you got
dean
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh man
i was feeling that i know it's about to
come with my lakeside okay we gotta
start you know what let's start it over
okay so i can turn the mic out okay
[Music]
i guess i guess i'm gonna hear this
[Laughter]
podcast
i might even keep that in anyway yeah
it's hilarious
[Laughter]
two old guys trying to figure it out
yeah yeah all right uh let's see
this keeps happening this is the problem
it's like i use my
you know when you when you're a one-man
show dean i hear you dude
i can't afford a producer yes they're
like where's your dude at i'm like what
i do have a guy that's helping me out
but i couldn't be here today but it's
still you know what i mean all right
here we go
all right that's better ladies and
gentlemen
to the second try welcome back to
ripping with griffin
there we are
all right dean delray there's a singing
mic i
always give it to the guests whatever
you got let me see
let the dell raisers know
[Music]
yes we are on a friday
[Music]
afternoon
[Music]
all out in the open
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
podcast mr jane
[Music]
all right we did it all right the fun is
over
that was our that was our uh our our
interpretation of p-funk 1979. yeah it's
a great man that uh made that for me
uh you know and then it's like i got
actually i got a lot of great music from
people
oh yeah all these kids and producers and
just like rap producers and stuff like
that they send me all this uh
great music you can take the headphones
off if you don't want them anymore yeah
you don't need to have phones anymore
yeah i'll just know if it doesn't work
you can put it down on the ground
um so anyways yeah so this is dean
delray long time friend
known you forever um i think it's the
first time we've been sat down like this
in a podcast i know you do a podcast
what's the name of your podcast again
i got a podcast network now called
cactus radio network cactusradio.com
and uh my 10 years let there be talk 10
years of
july 12th jesus yeah 10 years man
i know i'm like i can't even believe it
actually you know
and then and then i do one called the
grail where i feature people that make
stuff
and uh handmade [ __ ] like boots and cars
and that's good you know architects
whatever and then
marin and i got a brand new one called
dark fonzie
and then i've got this uh spiritual guru
lady
named byron katie who uh it's like the
female tony robbins
oh wow yeah i got a podcast with i
produced that one i'm not on that
and uh she's out there killing it wow
look at that
yeah it's amazing how the art form or
the platform has grown
and like in the in that 10 years right
it's just like
oh man i mean especially i was laughing
like during covet people are like i'm
going to start a podcast i'm like
good luck with with that you know
people always go like whoa whoa what
should i do and i'm like
man i you know don't have guests
you know because that's going to be hard
as [ __ ] you know i have guests and you
even said it yeah it's
really it's like especially during like
when the cove and even now and still and
even still just regularly trying to get
guests unless you're like
unless you've got a book or a producer
or you want these big podcasts i mean
there's just tears or levels of like you
know
rogan being at the top you know it's
like rogan
it's probably the the top right and then
like everything underneath that
it's like you know yeah marin adam
carolla and those kind of guys but
like i don't even count marin in that
because he just does audio
yeah he's like a strictly audio podcast
and it's a totally different experience
you know you're doing audio and video
it's a whole different thing
um you know i don't you know you know no
one is better than the other but it's
just like damn dude
i'm not getting 300 million from spotify
yeah i know like
you know i mean like that jason bateman
you know he just sounded like an 80
million dollar deal
and it was only for spotify to have it
like a w
or i think it was spotify or amazon one
of them to have it a week early
they don't even they're not even owning
the show like hey can we have it a week
early and here's 80 million and these
guys are on
movies and huge tv shows well but and
but that's the thing though i find that
some of the more like the more famous
recognizable people are seeing like well
how can i
monetize this yeah and they're just
doing it like not even just like in
podcast world but like you know you take
someone like snoop dogg
yeah you know he's been around for so
long he's like an old vet he's an old
dude now really in a rap game but now
he's just like a
um uh an entertainer and he's just like
it's a brand name snoop dogg so you just
go let's make a let's put him on this
all right let's put him on that you know
once he crossed with martha stewart
it was like people are like oh wow this
is on
and you know what's funny is like uh i
always say
like podcasting and voiceovers are for
like me the ugly dudes
yeah yeah i mean like
but we foreign love them but now they're
like all you know uh here comes jack
black
and uh well now they'll care if they
find out if he wasn't really a dog
they'll be
upset yeah they're like you know only a
dog could be a dog yeah
they they used a man to voice over
scooby
and it was a white man yeah
scooby is a brown dog
[Laughter]
oh my god but yeah you know like i i
just got a voiceover agent after a
hundred years
and i'm like uh you know all this
stuff's going to people
and i'm like kids don't care they're not
like brad pitt's killing it as the log
you know it's like they just like a cool
voice that's actually a hard game to get
into but it is i've had a voice over
agent for a while and actually
every job i've ever gotten a lot of it
is just like
through word of mouth or like this
producer knew me from something else but
like
like in terms of like going doing an
audition i don't think i've ever booked
a role
from an audition oh i mean when i first
moved to la
i got four voiceovers the first month
and i made like 12 grand i was like wow
i'm gonna be rich
yeah i mean it was like instantly this
guy's like hey can you sing
uh a diet dr pepper commercial i go oh
yeah i went over and he goes hey what
about this one here
california avocados and next thing you
know i'm getting checks
and then he's like wait i think i can
just do this with a little vocal
enhancer and he just took all the gigs
oh really and since then i've been
trying to get a
voiceover agent forever and yeah it's
tough i've done
you know again like i've i think
actually i think i did get like a
couple but they were like they weren't
high paying gigs it was like some
nickelodeon type shows
you know yeah and then those things go
like one run or like one season and it's
like it's not that serious but
you know it is um damn i put my hair
looks like i'm crazy because i usually
have the headphones on so i don't worry
about it but
but you i mean but i'm just you like the
hawk
like yeah i was like i don't know what's
going on with your [ __ ] um
well during the [ __ ] lockdown i was
like you got to get a dog and get a
mohawk you know i saw a road warrior
this is what i did with
my beard dude i just like what it was
like i remember when i
the thing started and i just shaved my
mustache for the first time in like you
know
oh yeah 30 years just to see yeah then
it just became like who cares
i know you know like we're just living
in this who cares world like we don't
care what we look like we don't care
what we sound like we don't care like
you know
and then it's like then the world sort
of started up again and then it like
stopped again they were just like now
we're in this state of just like waiting
for it to close down again i mean i
i don't know what's happening out there
but you know i don't know but not even
to get into that
like so like we know like yeah we've
known each other
for a freaking long ass time 11 years
yeah my first time like even knowing
anything about you was just like
you know just people talking about you
you know yeah oh that guy dean yeah he's
like like there wasn't a show you would
turn down you know it would be like you
know it would be like oh yeah
uh yeah yeah then you'd be like yeah
there's this great room in uh
monrovia i just got you know i'm gonna i
was on that motorcycle
i'd be like i did paramount tonight
bakersfield
and modesto yeah i'd be like how the
hell are you doing all these shows and
it just became a thing and then you just
like always around and you just like
stuck it out stuck it out stuck it out
and then you like kind of guy do like
you count your shows you still do
yeah which is like crazy to me i've
never even thought to do that i look
back on it now thinking like man i wish
i would have counted my shows yeah
i well i thought about i'll count them
in case i
you know ever do a documentary or a book
and then i just kept going and then i
started using it
actually later like wait have i done
this room and i looked oh yeah i did
this room i have some notes
oh wow your booker's an [ __ ] yeah
your [ __ ] guy written sound system
sucks
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah hey no mass
you know wow you are one of those
you were in there being a karen i
changed it to tammy i think tammy
i think tammy's the worst one you know
they bleach their own hair because they
can't afford it
i'm tammy but here's the thing man like
um
you know as much as like we've like hung
out we feel like going on the road you
know i don't even know if we've like
talked about the origins of even what
you've even done you know so i'm sure
you've talked about this a million times
on other things but my odd my small
audience doesn't know anything about it
so
yeah so like you know we're like where
are you from like you started in where
well i grew up in the bay area i was i
was born in yosemite dude
really yeah in the park man i lived
there you were born in the park
in the park yeah oh man talk about
trailer trash
actually no trailers in yosemite oh wow
yeah
they're like you would tent trash i was
long cabin trash [ __ ]
log cabin is next level it's funny
sometimes i tell people i'm from
yosemite and they're like
did you live with the bears right
but yeah i agree but wait wait but there
is there a city in like yosemite is not
just the park
it is the park and uh it's very small
this is 1966 i'm [ __ ] old 55
and it's a it was just a small community
if you work there if you your
rangers and store workers and uh
uh there's one there's two hotels there
the iwani and then the uh yosemite lodge
and you know people kind of also the
people that work right
they also live in the park because you
couldn't go what did your parents do
uh my mom worked at the iwa then dad was
kind of uh
like a uh you know part-time
you know helper ranger dude meets uh he
kind of in everything ran the ice rink
uh and then delivered the all the
supplies to the shops and hotel
and oh that's just uh everything guy up
there and then my grandma worked there
too
wow yeah she was family business she
worked at the store
so they disappointed they knew how when
you left the park they were like how
dare you
oh man you know what's funny when i i i
was there for years uh
and then i didn't go for like 10 years i
was like ah man i'm not going there you
know and then i went back
and drove in and i was like oh man
how can i live here you know that's what
i started yeah yeah
i think a lot of people feel like that
when you when you leave a small place
and you go to any sort of metropolitan
city yeah
and then you just just having access to
the things you have access to
you know either you love small town life
yeah
you know simple life but you either love
it then when you leave
and you realize oh [ __ ] yeah yeah
there's something about it when you come
back and you know there's a tunnel you
go through and then you come out
and there's a half dome over here and
there's just waterfalls and you're like
whoa you know it's like a complete
decompressor man it's the most beautiful
spot i've ever been
i really see do you miss it at all well
i love
going a lot but unfortunately
it's like one of the number one tourist
spots in the world
right so it's hard for me to go like
oh right right right like i don't have a
sex when your home is not like
yeah these people don't really respect
it like a home
yeah like i want to go for like a week
like with marin i'm like
yeah let's go hiking and then i'm i'm
entering lotteries
each morning to get into the hike i want
to do and i'm like right
it's going on here but uh i do love it
and if i probably wasn't in the biz
maybe at this age i would just go up
there and work there you know oh i got
you like as a
volunteer or whatever how'd you get
something like
you know how did you get into music
because that part i don't think i've
ever
talked to you about that part of your
life so because it's almost like you've
had two different lives
you've lived two lifetimes it feels like
that right yeah yeah like
really three because when i was growing
up right you had your yosemite
kind of thing you know lifestyle hippie
you know and then
and then i get to the bay area and i'm
engulfed in like we didn't have tv up
there you know what i mean oh in
yosemite
yeah i think there's no team maybe one
channel there's no cable
up there or anything wow so once i get
into the bay area the floodgates open
and my mom was way into music taking me
to concerts at a young age
and i just was that was it for me
music i had to do it i grew up in the
bay area i said you know you got all the
music there
uh and all the clubs it's like a mecca
of music in the 70s and 80s
really oh my god you got everything from
like say the grateful dead
jefferson airplane and all that hippie
stuff in the 60s
then you get into the 70s rock uh
out there like santana and all that and
then you get into the 80s of like
metallica that's
and that was all in the bay area that's
all in san francisco ground
zero so was it uh why was it what drew
you to the rock though because it was
rock that really grabbed you yeah yeah
it was just like kiss as a kid it was
like comic bookie and fire
and everything so makeup and all that
yeah i loved kiss as a kid
and then from there it just went you
know ac dc
and uh van halen and then from there i
got way into like prince
and nwa just me and all this music you
know was
engulfed in me man it was i liked all
music
but okay so but when did it when did you
you know what got you into like because
you were a performer you were like what
what was all that about how did that
come about i was
so you leave yosemite you're now in this
area your parent your mom's taking you
to concerts and you're like okay
i want that i want to do that yeah so
what was the next step
neighbor was a drummer and he gave me a
drum kit
i played that for like two weeks and i
was like nah
i traded it in i loved ac dc so i got a
guitar
same one as the angus the guy in the
band and then i got a guitar and then
everyone in the neighborhood was playing
guitar because of angus and eddie van
halen
and they're like we need singers no one
wanted to sing
and every band needed a singer so then
the high school was doing one of those
kind of battle of the bands
and me and some guys put a band together
and played the high
school you were jack black before jack
black was jack black oh yeah yeah
when i see him right i'm like yeah
people are like you're like jack black i
go hey man i think i'm older than him
but
i did live that by the way one of my
favorite movies still to this i love
school of rock oh man
it's just like that is a classic perfect
movie i can watch that movie
you could just turn it on at any point
and i'll continue to watch it i love
that movie so much
that's a smoker film man and and
wow does he kill it in that so hard and
the kids
are so good everyone yeah yeah yeah
everyone's great they nailed it with
that because you know
that movie and uh the
almost famous me being from music
almost famous is the masterpiece music
film
because as a musician you watch it and
you go all right we're going to wait for
the corny stuff to come and it never
comes
yeah yeah dead unreal yeah you know so
those two and then of course the comedy
spinal tap
yeah yeah you got those three yeah you
know but i got
you know so then you start so you you
became a singer
yeah so out of out of necessity you know
and that was
that was weird being a singer because
it's just like really
bizarre when you first start singing
you're just you don't know what you're
doing yeah when you're writing your own
music or you're taking
joking lessons or you were just like
okay yeah i was taking vocal lessons my
mom would drop me off on thursdays
old lady with a piano
and you're like shy you know there's
people in the other room yeah yeah
you're thinking they're in there like oh
this guy you know
but then we i remember every week we'd
sing um
hello is it me you're looking for
that was the one richie yeah lionel
ritzy which i was glad because i got to
learn different
types of singing but then you just
you learn to sing uh you either can sing
or you can't
yeah and what you need to learn is
longevity how to
keep your voice without going bad that's
really what you're like you know what
i'm having that problem right now i just
started going on youtube and doing vocal
lessons because i was like oh
something's going on with my voice
i can tell because i do to just on the
podcast and i sing and so for the past
like six seven months i've been like oh
man this isn't going right
something's wrong yeah and i thought it
was like oh is it because of age and
then when i
look into research it actually has
nothing to do with aids no it has
everything to do with like you know
keeping up your uh whatever that is and
so i'm trying to figure that out now
yeah it's a muscle
even when we took uh the whole year off
of doing comedy
you and i did our first show back
together at the the beach
and you know i'm gonna be talking only
20 minutes
but if you haven't done that for you
know a year
yeah your voice gets tired so you got to
warm it up and you got to keep that
thing it's a muscle
and you got to keep it you know working
all the time when i'm doing weekends
like five shows five one hours like i
just did at the punch line
i'll warm up at the room for sure hey
what do you do what's your warm-up
there's uh i got it on my computer which
is great but there's
send me that i will send it over to you
and i'll show you how to do it yeah yeah
yeah but there's stuff like
uh this thing called a lip trill where
it's like
[Music]
i just saw this on a youtube video and
the guy was going like this
yeah then you do this oh wow
what you're doing is you're creating a
uh
you know like a uh a little bit of uh
pressure that you know warms up the
vocal cords instead of going
and you're doing all that and then
there's these yeah
[Music]
it's crazy and and same and how long do
you do it
i usually do it uh for about 15 minutes
when i can kind of feel it's good
some people do it a half hour some
people do what they call a warm
down now which i never got that came
later
where after the show they do this warm
down
what's up everybody this is eric griffin
and i'm here to talk to you about better
help
uh you know i love talking about therapy
i do real world advice from a grown-ass
man
it's i know it's very helpful just to
talk to somebody just to have some like
a common sense approach but
sometimes you need a little bit more
help you need to delve deeper and that's
what therapy is all about
so i do highly recommend better help
there are many things that interfere
with our happiness
as you know we've had the craziest
almost two years right now and it
it's taken its toll so i really
highly recommend you you know talk to a
professional they don't solve your
problem so much as they help you
pinpoint the causes and some like coping
mechanisms to help you get through it
that's what this is all about you'll get
timely and thoughtful responses plus you
can schedule weekly video or phone
sessions all without having to sit
in an uncomfortable waiting room because
that's always uncomfortable so
listen um i don't know what your issues
are but it could be
many number of things depression stress
anxiety anger
family problems grief self-esteem
anything you can think of like that
talking to a trained professional it
will do wonders for helping you
really organize your thoughts and find
out why you're feeling the way you're
feeling
everything's confidential it's
convenient um
look i just i highly recommend it i've
gone through it i worked on boundary
issues with it there's sometimes you
work on things
you don't even realize that
what are the causes and where it came
from and then you start to really your
eyes open up and you can start to see
when things are happening so look i want
you to start living a happier life today
as a listener you'll get 10 off your
first month by visiting our sponsor at
betterhelp.com
griffin that's help h-e-l-p
join over one million people who've
taken charge of their mental health
that's betterhelp.com
h-e-l-p better help help dot com slash
griffin for ten
percent off your first month
get out there and get some help let's
get back to the show
which is really crazy like to bring your
voice back down
i don't know that technique and i'm sure
it's out there but
it's a it's a definitely a thing and i
realized when you're singing
how to get the high notes it's kind of
like when you're yawning you ever yawn
and you go like
that's how you sing man it's like it
opens everything up
once you realize that like oh that's the
way you want to be
all in here loose yeah or like even they
talk about
above your you know absolutely like
and i know when i when i started doing
this one
and it was like the guy was saying like
make it feel like it's above
that you know and then when you're doing
it you kind of you really
you know you have to like you know you
go oh yeah you almost feel it go from
there to there and i was just like oh i
didn't even
you know you know i use my voice all the
time and i don't even think and i just
kind of like
you know i have a i have an alright
singing voice when i'm
when i'm in the thing so i just go like
oh okay and then when i wasn't able to
do certain things i was like oh [ __ ]
yeah
yeah i mean we need our voice holy
smokes if we don't have it like
i've seen guys where their voice is
blown out by the fourth show on a
weekend yeah
and they're like dude you got two more
to go yeah you know and they're like
and booze is the worst for your voice it
dries it all out alcohol
so you know people are drinking and you
know he got to be like
straight up like water or good warm tea
and then just my technique man
understanding like how to use the power
of the pa
yeah for sure totally man you know it's
it's while
also i can see notes it's really weird
like if i want to hit a high note
i can kind of see where to go like
you know like it's really wild you know
i can actually see the note and go for
it oh that's man that's amazing like i
knew
i knew something was up in my voice when
i was doing because when i used to be
able to do karaoke and i used to be able
to do purple rain right oh yeah and at
the end of purple rain i used to be able
to hit all that you know
oh yeah yeah that's so high but i used
to be able to really get it and then one
time i was like trying to get and i was
like
you know like this [ __ ] was happening i
was like what happened to my singing
voice you know
then i thought oh my god do i have
polyps am i losing my voice am i too old
and then i'm actually doing some
research i was like oh wait a minute
i need to do some vocal exercises stuff
i've never thought i needed to do but
you know as you get older i mean that it
is partly about getting older in terms
of like
your voice isn't just like you know of
course not ready to go not ready to go
so i was like all right so i need so i
just really started like
you know i played i do i try to do it in
the shower so i just put like you know
my little you know the phones are
waterproof so i just have it in the
thing and i just follow this guy's
technique it's like all right first do
this
[Music]
yeah and i'll start i want to start
doing it because i really do feel like
and then because i do this every week i
know in the comments people go what's up
with griff's voice
chris's not hitting the notes what's
happening on your patreon
anymore i'm like [ __ ] yeah what's going
on with me you got to start lip syncing
[Laughter]
hilarious 96 griffin
yeah man so i get i used to love going
to karaoke and all that kind of stuff so
it's like
i can uh i knew something was up but
that's interesting to know that it is
really about vocal
exercises and and getting that muscle
going uh with anything
so like so you know you cause i always
see these old pictures of you oh yeah
i was these old pictures of you and and
it's interesting because when i look at
that i go
like i said like you'd literally lived a
different life
like that version of dean delray like i
don't know that guy at all yeah you know
what i mean
and so like you know like so
when did it become like a thing where
you were making a living
well you know pre uh illegal downloading
guys like me that weren't big stars but
like you know
blue collar bands that had a record deal
oh got you could kind of you know
go out and make a living selling cds and
merch and tickets and everything
and uh no problem you know like
and then it came to that point to where
you're like hey you want to buy a cd
after the show they're like oh no
my friend downloaded it we love it thank
you and they're like oh you know like
they don't even realize they're telling
you we stole it
you know because they don't they don't
put it together okay that's interesting
let's talk about this
it's interesting that you say this i
liken it to uh
you know things have to evolve right so
for instance um
you know photo maps went away of course
you know what i mean they went away
because technology
made it so you could so then that was
like kind of a business that was just
like hey we don't need this anymore
yeah you know what i mean so there's
because i have two schools of thought
about like downloading music
and and it's amazing how because i
remember i don't know if you remember
this app called audio galaxy
i don't know that one i just remember it
was right around napster
this was one of those it was an offshoot
one but i just remember you could
download a bunch of things at once and
it would take like you know
after 10 hours you'd be like oh [ __ ] i
got like
i got the whole beatles album or
something like that you go to sleep you
wake up you're still like
you know but it would be like this
amazing thing and now dude like i
literally
i can download the entire beatles
collection the entire beatles collection
live albums uh bootleg mixes
in literally two minutes i could have
the entire [ __ ] on my computer
instantly and so two schools of thought
with this
it's just i always okay so when i look
at like you think of like sports
you know yeah you are paying for cable
and stuff like that you know
but for the most part if i wanted like
in our younger years
you wanted to watch the nba it was free
absolutely you know cause you turn on
nbc and there it is
yeah the nba's on uh and so but if you
wanted to go watch it live
that's what you had to pay a certain
amount of money right and that was where
the you know the money was generated
along with like the tv revenue and all
that kind of
yeah and then the logos and all that so
you have all that so
there was a part of it like imagine if
you didn't have that exposure to it at
all
would you even be interested in it would
you even be able to watch it so you have
to get the product out there
right now in terms of like music like
i remember having to buy cds i remember
having to go on the record
but i wouldn't necessarily take a chance
on something i've never heard before
so it was like you know i found that
when we were we were able to download
music
i became a fan of people i never thought
i would become a fan of right
right because he had access to it
because i had exactly i had access to it
and so it was like
i felt like the musicians then needed to
change
how they monetized their things right
but i can understand on the other side
of it is like hey this is how we were
doing it we sell cds yeah
every our music is supposed to be we
should get paid for any time somebody
plays it
i don't necessarily agree with that so
like where did you stand on that and did
you change your
outlook on it or how have you evolved or
what do you think about it
well i mean we can talk about it for
hours because it's such a big deal to me
nuanced yeah yeah it um
here's what i say uh there's there's
numerous people out there
that have all kinds of different
attitudes one of them
i think the biggest was ah [ __ ] those
rich rock stars
i'm taking the music you know i'm
totally for
streaming paying for you know amazon
music
or itunes or whatever i love that
big time uh what i don't like is
what was going on before that which was
the illegal
downloading of stealing of the records
you know they're not even paying a
streaming platform
at least the streaming platform you know
they're robbing the musicians right now
you know they give you like a a penny or
whatever a stream
but eventually i think they're going to
battle
and get this uh equal rights well i
think that they already
i think they already have i'm starting i
mean the music i mean
you know when that one kid that was
killed that rapper he signed a 10
million dollar deal
yeah i mean i'm saying they they figured
out how to monetize and
the music industry figured out how to
get into the streaming game
but one contention i have about what you
said is yeah i don't think
because let me tell you my perspective i
remember when we were able to start
burning our own cd
right yeah yeah and that's when i knew
we were being robbed right
right that's what so it wasn't about the
musicians nah and i tell you when it
really wasn't about the music so like i
remember being like so i can get
50 cds for six dollars right and then
like so
then why am i paying 17 for a cd okay
so then you start to go well i like such
and such artists and you were like okay
so this is how they make money but then
come to find out
the artist wasn't even making money now
so so
then it became a thing like why the [ __ ]
am i paying 17 for this
to the record kind of right what are
they doing so this so i disagree with
you about like i don't think people were
like [ __ ] these rock artists
right no no they were like the money's
not even getting to them well i'll go
see them live
that's where they get the money i'm
talking about like when lars from
metallica was like look napster's doing
this and they're like ah [ __ ] lars or
whatever you know and turned out he was
right he's like we better fix this now
or else it's going to go up in flames uh
my point
on it is you know the people
and this is really uh a long going thing
the people need to realize and
some do and some don't that the band
gets like a penny
or a dime or some big big stars maybe a
dollar
once they realize that then go join
their patreon
that's what i always tell people and and
start going towards the bands you know
not the big bands of course they've
restructured their deals and stuff but
i'm talking about people like you and i
yeah we're out there everything we do is
free
pretty much you know podcasting a lot of
the shows they're papered rooms or
whatever
and we work and look i'm not complaining
at all
ever i'm just let people know hey this
is what's going on then they go oh i
didn't know
i thought you got a lot of money from
spotify like everybody else yeah
yeah no i'm just letting you know i
never complain
if you're complaining get the [ __ ] out
yeah you know or just keep doing it
you know but um that's my point i let
people know
hey i'm not getting any money so if you
do want to go to the patreon please do
well i mean i'm just saying like it
seems like the bit look
the technology when technology's changed
the the business right so it's like you
know it it is what it is
in terms of like you know i understand
that people think like
like what are you so the the question
becomes what are you doing this
music for are you doing this music just
to make money or
do you think the only way you should
make money is people listening to the
music
and i because like i always say go
see your favorite artists live it's a
different experience
i say it all the time no go see them
live go pay that ticket because that's
for for the longest time that's where
people make their money
well i tell people this you know you and
i know this more than
anybody it's like hey coming to
sacramento this weekend
man gonna catch you next time and
perfect example of this
i went to tom petty at the hollywood
bowl a week later he died
okay a week later it was his last show
ever and so many people
were like oh i was gonna catch him next
time around
yeah and then when covet happened in the
lockdown and it looked like we weren't
maybe gonna do comedy for a couple years
or who knows i was like for all you
people that
say gonna catch you next time there
might not be a next time
yeah and for numerous reasons one you
didn't draw enough at the club they
don't have you back
two you maybe you're not alive three
maybe you tap out of the business or
whatever
that's how grinding it is so it's got to
be
vital for the fan uh when somebody comes
to town that i want to see
i'm there i mean i'm like oh my god i
gotta see prince at the forum you know
yeah man it's um yeah it's a
it's an it's an amazing thing but it's
like i am like i
totally see the both sides of it because
i'm on both sides of it um
but you know
i mean you know what we've learned in
this um pandemic is like
you know you find you just have to find
different ways to monetize your
personality and art form yeah but it's
just interesting to me to hear about
somebody who like
you really def you really lived through
it yeah i mean so
when we were going through that
transition as a society i mean i'm sure
it was hard for all those
mid-range artists i'm sure it was hard
for like you know but come
come to find out it wasn't just hard for
you guys it was hard for like tlc too
oh yeah you know it was hard for like
you know you because we got all these
stories later i mean this was the
backlash i mean
the backlash to the industry in the
music industry was when these stories
would come out
and the number one artist in the country
was like broke
yeah and that made us all as a consumer
you were like whoa
whoa whoa whoa where's the money flow
yeah like where's the money flow going
because
i didn't know that i was making a record
company rich yeah yeah
you know what i mean yeah i used to go
this record company i'd be like this see
the cds used to be like seventeen
dollars
bro they first came out there were 25. i
remember i got jane's addiction nothing
shocking it was like 27 dollars
right i was like whoa it's
state-of-the-art
it turns out later it wasn't you're like
i want the two dollar vinyl give me that
back i remember how the record store you
said remember warehouse records oh yeah
hell yeah i remember how it changed it
was so amazing like so you walk in
yeah and it was all records yeah okay
like vinyl records yep
and cassette tapes and then like a few
years ago by then it was like
half the store was vinyl records and
then they had this little cd section
yeah
you know and i remember the first cd i
read my first cd was
the faith album george mike record that
was my
first great rap cd yeah and i had this
ridiculous little cd player that like
you know you couldn't you couldn't
breathe on it or that [ __ ] was
skipped
you know what i mean i'm talking about
you had to have it in a stationary
but it was like i was like oh this is
amazing i love this sound you know
auntie skip came out oh my god with the
walkman and all that stuff that was
stuff was great and i had the yellow one
dude i had cassette tapes all the time
too man that was my thing
i had two oh man i remember i had two
cassette tapes
yeah huey lewis in the news you know i
want a new udriver oh yeah sports right
one of the greatest records ever made so
i had that and then i had like
uh the other one was like the purple
rain and
i would listen to those at night and it
might be my stupid cassette tape player
so like but then the cd the store
changed yeah and then it was like
all cds yeah when the cd first came out
it was in the long box
yeah yeah and then they were like
[ __ ] with it yeah too much room
so they just switched to no box yeah it
was like oh
all right so they could get thousands in
the store and then it was like the
the cassette tapes gone gone even before
vinyl cassettes were like no no who's
doing that nobody
then you started to be like how
ridiculous it was to have to like you
know skip
forward and like to find your song auto
reverse auto
all that stuff yeah or how about you had
to turn it over
oh the worst yeah you could take it out
turn it over eight track was even
crazier mid
track it'd be like all running
empty running
you know and then then all of a sudden
it was just all cds and then like the
you know the downloading started but
you know i just feel like that the music
in industry itself they they got over on
us for
many many many years and then it was
like the napster and all that stuff was
just a backlash i mean there is a
i'm not saying it's right but there is a
feeling of like yo
get let us hear your let us hear yeah
let us hear what you got going on
and then then let us decide after we
hear it okay and now i'll support you
yeah you know i mean like look i never
complained
yeah i played music 25 years never
complained
i just tell people they go like hey how
did you just get out of music and start
doing comedy
and i was like well have you ever done
anything 25 years
you know eventually it started to
dwindle away the money
and then i had to get a job i didn't
complain and then one day i just said
you know what if i'm going to uh do
something for free
i'm going to try something i always
wanted to do comedy and that's
exactly what happened i was like i'm
gonna do i'm gonna do this you know and
i'm fine with it
and i've never ever complained i'm not
i'm not one of those guys it's like all
this [ __ ]
like some tumbleweed i was making money
and then you guys [ __ ]
no you just [ __ ] adapt and figure it
out
and move on you know yeah yeah
for sure and i think that even in the
comedy industry
we're seeing like this huge change and
how how it works too big time we're the
we're the gatekeepers now not the not
the big
big dogs at comedy central that's not
even on my radar you know
yeah it's funny how that is the thing
now it's like it used to be this thing
where you need you know
you know comedy central you know so
you're supposed to be the place where
you go and it's like
i don't know one person i know that
watches comedy central i didn't talk
about it it's not on anymore yeah
i don't even know what i i don't know
what's going on there but like
you know they they they alternative
comedied themselves right out of the
market
right i mean right right you know all
the alternative whatever whoever
you know i really feel like the problem
was like there was a lack of
there was a lack of taste a broadening
of the taste too it was just like one
taste
well that happened like uh anything say
uh music business they're like okay
we're into this kind of music
right now it's grunge only yeah yeah now
it's uh
alternative rock now it's hip-hop only
instead of like you know there's tons of
taste out here
we better you know work i mean you know
i went to meetings and it was like
you're too old you know
if you look at my instagram uh the
numbers here these people are 25 to 35.
yeah that's the demographic
uh i'm not i don't have 60 year olds on
here they don't even work
instagram yeah it's uh i know i know
it's so
so strange yeah but you know you know
it's funny when we talk about like
i think the separation of music was a
problem when we were kids
but you know what i think really changed
that was
uh trl on mtv yeah i think it
i think it changed the music landscape
you know this is just my opinion
but i remember when trl was at its
height so they would have
this um chart that they would have and
be like
i remember the this is the top 10 songs
according to trl
but what they found was it was like it
wasn't a particular type of music
no it became like literally what pop
music
means it's like it doesn't mean but i'm
saying pop music doesn't mean like what
we think oh it's poppy yeah it meant
popular popular right and so then you
had this
chart and it would be like rap rock
alternative yeah country it would be
like and i think that that
i think that that slapped all of the
that generation in the face and they
were just like
oh yeah it doesn't have to be the rock
chart it doesn't have to be the
the r b chart it doesn't have to be the
hip-hop chart it doesn't have to be the
you know it was like oh these are the
ten songs that we love
and they're and they're from all
different genres that's the same thing
with comedy i i
uh my argument is like it comes down to
a great song
okay all different races love a great
song yeah
and with with comedy it comes down to
great jokes
i'm in the room you're in the room at
the comedy store there's multi races and
ages and types of people in this room
are they laughing yeah they are so it
doesn't matter
it just matters do the people like the
joke or the song
you know i i i say that all the time
about comedy uh one of the things that i
love about it so much
live performing uh the thing that like
always
moves me is i'm looking out at a group
of people that one
don't know each other right two they're
from all different
ages races demographics uh economic
backgrounds
and their collectively laughing at me
yeah and then the weirdest part to me is
a lot of times no one knows who you are
the first minute you walk on
yeah they don't know you and in a matter
hopefully
in a matter of a minute or so they're
all laughing at
a total stranger well you know what
though but you know what though
that doesn't even matter because i feel
like now i have
some notoriety enough where like and i
start to feel it too like when i'm at
especially shows in l.a they'll be like
hey eric griffin eric griffin and then i
i see
i see some people go oh yeah and i'm
like oh so these people know me right
but here's the thing man they don't give
a [ __ ]
yeah that's like i've brought up
really famous like i'd be like like a
famous person drops in
yeah okay i won't even say a certain
name yeah that's right and i'll be like
guys you're gonna love this so and so
and everybody's like
oh my god you got a minute a minute
a minute tops you got a minute maybe two
minutes
you get the you're famous you're famous
and then the whole crop starts to go
is this too funny i know is this chick
funny like this
yeah then they're like oh maybe he
hasn't done it in a while
and then they're just looking at they're
just yeah yeah so so what i'm saying is
famous famous i know there is i get that
about like you really have to like get
them you know yeah oh yeah but i'm
saying when you do
and it trips me out of like i'm a total
stranger
and i'm just like it's like if you were
at a party right and i'm in the corner
and they're like what's this guy about
and all of a sudden they're like
laughing you know like it's stranger
like at a party
that's what it feels like to me you know
well you know dean i got to tell you man
like i remember
when we first started hanging out um i
instantly was like oh this is a cool
dude yeah you know what i mean and then
we're like you know
we're close in age yeah so that's like a
thing too like in comedy a lot of times
you're like
i end up because i started late too even
though
right not as late as you yeah but i
still started late in comparison to a
lot of people that i know
so you're like you're always like the
oldest statesman around so it was
interesting to have somebody like around
my age that we could share a different
the same experiences the same thought
process you know
but there was a thing where it's like i
don't like hanging out with people i
don't think they're funny
right oh yeah i just i just i can't do
it keen heart and said the same thing on
the podcast i'm not gonna pretend i
can't do it right yeah so i hadn't seen
you do comedy yet yeah
and we were hanging out yeah and my
thing was like i like this guy
so i avoided watching you for a long
time because people were talking [ __ ]
about you yeah yeah of course
people were talking smack stuff and i
was like oh god what if he's not funny
how am i gonna like
how am i gonna have to like not talk to
him anymore yeah not so
extreme but it was it would be difficult
i don't get it and then i
and then i i saw you and i was like
thank god
this guy's funny and then we just
started doing some stuff you know
you you've come with me on the road a
few times you're going on the road on
your own you're bringing people and it's
like
you know it's like um you know it is i
know that thing you must feel because
you know it's like i like being an odd
looking guy sometimes yeah so for you
too it must be the same kind of thing
here's this like weird character you got
tattoos you gotta
you know you're you know you look like
you know somebody's dad yeah then you go
on there and you just have this way
about how you do the comedy that and i i
enjoy watching that you know what i mean
i enjoy seeing like you
and then the people enjoying you and
kind of being like surprised
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's always a
great feeling it is it is
it it's funny because when i started you
know they're like
you should be the rocker comic or you
should be the biker comic and i was like
nah nah i'm gonna be a comic yeah it's
funny how you get typecasted or people
put you in
and it's the reason why people don't
want to put their personal business out
there it's like
if you'd be like okay i'm bisexual i'm
gay whatever then all of a sudden now
yeah you have to be that comic yeah like
i like dal magical
big time and he's hispanic not once did
he ever talk about that he doesn't like
being like that type
right so i learned so much from him
because when i was coming up
you know they had the uh you know
refried fridays
and the crack em ups and there were all
these like uh
you know uh you know an urban show a
hispanic show
and i was just kind of like i just want
to be able to do all these and just be
a comedian that's another reason why i
moved to new york for three years you
know i was just like oh
i want to be not an l.a comic i want to
be a comic
and and learn a different uh rhythm
there and everything but
you know i grew up on comedy and i
[ __ ]
loved it man as a kid cheech and chong
pryor carlin hicks these guys were like
gods to me at the same time i was
listening to a record like
say i'd put on uh you know ac dc record
the next record would be
richard pryor yeah you know i mean all
the time at a party
and and i always wanted to do comedy
so i kind of understood what
good comedy was and what bad comedy was
you know
yeah even if it's hard you know and then
there's so many like different factors
that go into it i mean it's like
i mean even for me like i remember i i
knew when i was going to cop like when i
was going to doing colleges
pre being even a little bit
pseudo-famous
yeah it was a different experience you
know because you're going and you're
like okay these people don't really know
who you are
you have to deal with these you have to
deal with these like sensitive ass
bitch-ass college kids
oh yeah you know they're just so stupid
they're the smartest stupidest sensitive
people i've ever like yeah
you know when people in college like
they're so stupid about
life oh you know what i mean yeah they
they just had like their freshman
psychology so now they think like oh
and they just they're just so overly
sensitive about certain things
and then it's like and comedy is one of
those things that they don't they
haven't lived
they can't understand they can't fathom
that
we're just this is just an entertaining
thing that we're doing
even if we're talking about a really
tough subject they don't know how to
disassociate from like this like
you know feeling that they have you know
what i mean like yeah they're like oh
yeah so but anyways when you're not
famous at all
yeah that's a lot to deal with oh man
then you're getting like these letting
your
your agents calling you what happened at
the show oh yeah
you know there's this one girl called
her father and then school is like you
know it's like that then you had to deal
with that kind of stuff
once the workaholics and all that kind
of stuff man yeah completely changed
same act yeah same act and they're like
oh yeah
it's montez yeah but then i started to
go up top be like yes and if you if
you're sensitive
if you if you've never been into a show
i need you to get the [ __ ]
out now yeah cause you're about to be
you're about to go call your dad
so i want you to leave now yeah yeah
timmy's remove the tampons yeah
all you tammy's get out of here so you
know it's just
so what i'm saying is like there is a
level of like
you know what's you know what's going on
you know what i mean like you just have
this sort of
like and i see it even at like the you
know at the comedy store it's like
you know being a part of the comedy
store for the past like you know
in the past like eight years has been a
very
weird experience totally totally i mean
i i mean
the comedy store is my life it was the
reason i
really wanted to do con i was hanging
there in the 80s my buddy was stealing
coke
he'd be like hang here on the patio free
drinks i gotta make a lap and he would
go sell blow and
and we were there and you know watching
kennison
dice dude i was there man i would be
like wow
i remember i saw dice and i was like
what the [ __ ] he was
he was just you know he'd come on like
is that your girl
what a hole you know and they would go
we're out of here honey and
you know he was like trying to you know
clear the room out and i was like this
is
crazy [ __ ] you know so this is how dice
shook my hand the first time he ever met
me
oh how flat-handed yeah he just kept it
like this
wow i'll never forget that wow so
i you know to come to the store at 44
walk on the patio and go is this where
the open mic set
and you know people are like oh what the
[ __ ] is that guy you actually went to
the open mics oh i was doing the potluck
i was doing the potluck dude i remember
when i first got there i never did it
alex was the guy that picked the names
and he was telling me like yeah you know
when i started here guys would get
stabbed
you're trying to get their name in the
bucket before the other guy like oh
stab a dude on the patio and and
um yeah i was there and it was just
and it wasn't even you know i would say
there would be
50. now there would be 250. like right
before the lockdown
oh my god it'd just be like whoa but
they'd be like 50 and i didn't know
anyone i had no friends i'd just kind of
roll on there i'd sign up
and then those guys would try to roast
me you know when they're hosting that
was like the easy thing for them to do
roast each comic so i started you know
doing that open mic
and then when i started hosting i was
like i'm not gonna roast people
i'm gonna actually you know if they're
good i'm gonna say hey that was some
good [ __ ] man
and um you know just kind of went for a
positive vibe on it because i knew how
look it's great to be rough on people
because you know get out
if you can't handle it yeah yeah yeah
yeah but it's an element of life let's
let's
get let's go you know let's you know
clear this herd of uh yeah yeah because
like even when i
used to be a culling like when i first
met you
everybody was like yeah that's eric
griffin he's mean because he
remember you just showed like yeah
what's up hey look at who are these guys
get out of here you know like dude
you gotta be unapproachable because
[ __ ] will take all your energy
oh i call them time bandits yeah man you
know they come up they're like hey man
you got somewhere pretty quick how do
you
yeah how do you how did you do how do
you start comedy that's like you just
got to be like you know
the ones that just knew how to be cool
and like yeah i get this all the time
somebody else was telling me this i was
at supernova and then the chick was
saying to me like yes couple of these
new comics they're like
i don't think he likes me like talking
about me yeah [ __ ] i don't know you
yeah yeah yeah you know what i mean like
i don't know you so i'm supposed to like
every person like they'll suck all your
energy if every person i met i had to be
like
hey what's up man yeah so i just kind of
like i'm just chill
it's nothing personal yeah yeah and a
lot of times i'm getting ready to go on
man like my mind i'm trying to remember
these jokes these new jokes and
everything and they're like
hey man uh you know think i could open
for you in utah and i'm just like whoa
dude i'm f who are you you know and i'm
not being a dick but i'm in my
own mind not even just that the the the
the like as if
i don't know any comments yeah the
etiquette is crazy
like so you're asking me yo yeah i see
you coming to what you call it you don't
mind if it's like
i get to ask right because you're trying
to hustle do your thing i get it but
don't be mad
if i'm like no yeah yeah yeah
you don't think i have a like a a a
address book
full of comics i know trust and respect
and want to hang out and want to hang
with right
i send that photo to you all the time of
you and i on the couch at the la jolla
and i'm laughing because you're just
roasting on me you know you're like oh
here comes dean with his dumb ass
whatever
and i'm over there laughing on the on
that dumb green couch they had
like wicker couch my f you know but
man we've been talking so long now we
gotta wrap it up i gotta do this thing
but uh my favorite moment with you still
i and i was just who was i telling this
to the other i was telling this to
somebody the other day
but we're watching that bill murray
movie
oh my god what was the name of that
movie uh
i forget we're in um we're down there in
the
uh i gotta i gotta look it up because i
gotta and it was like
it was like this great uh wait wait we
gotta look it up
bill murray imdb bill murray movies
oh my god and we're down there at the
saint vincent
saint vincent and we're down there in
the um uh
where ontario ontario that's where it
was and so we're watching this movie
yeah and then let's go see this comedy
yeah because it's bill murray yeah i
thought he should have won oscar but
anyway
at the end of the movie there's this
great like because like
anything that has to do with mother and
son you get me oh yeah
so like i knew something was going to
happen remember that scene like it's
right before he goes
he's in the kitchen the kid is in the
kitchen and he says something to his mom
and i remember sitting there with you
and i went like this oh
yeah because it's middle of the day
too because i knew i was like oh this is
going to get me
yeah you know yeah and then like it was
like it was so like
emotional and moving i'm crying
and then i look over at your ass you're
crying yeah
you're looking at me and you you you go
look at those
two guys in their 40s balling in the
middle of the day and that just
made me i just wrote two hard dudes too
it was like this now here's exactly what
happened we're watching it right and i
you don't want to look yeah i don't want
to look at you and i go oh no
i'm going to cry and i'm holding my face
like a ventriloquist
right like oh no and i sit i hear and
over to the left of me
and i look over and i go oh eric's
crying
damn i am too
dude i heard the sniffle like this yeah
and i knew
i could oh and that sniffle gave me away
i'm like don't do it don't do it don't
do it
you know oh that was just great and it's
just like one of those moments where you
know i knew you know what it was that
moment i knew we'd be friends forever
yeah yeah yeah
even though we were already tied at that
point but but you helped me so much
man wow i mean there's some dudes out
there
that helped me like crap look i busted
my ass
you did you worked hard man yeah and
i've done over 5000 shows
but it was the help of being a
you know people going this guy's busting
his ass i'm gonna take him on the road
and learn the 20 minute art which is
[ __ ] light years of time when you're
new you're like
oh my god now i'm at 20 i'm like i'm
just starting this [ __ ]
and so you're out there learning the 20
and then
i'm bringing you up and you'd be like oh
you were terrible like whatever just
happened you know like you roasted me
for fun you know and
uh where do you think you lost them yeah
yeah yeah
and and and because that's how it was
for me when i was coming up yeah
those people you'd be like oh man yeah
yeah right before you go on stage if
you're gonna wear that you know it's
like
that's how those old cats used to be mad
yeah yeah it's just hardcore so but you
know what whatever doesn't kill you
makes you stronger yeah it was just
i i and look like i said you know i got
i became a paid regular at the store
and it's just like music i never did
anything for
money ever i love this so much that
even during the lockdown i was like oh
wow i finally found something i
love and it's gone yeah it's hard
[ __ ] gone man and i was like that's
such dean
luck you know i got i got good luck and
then until i don't
you know the man is like oh i was just
[ __ ]
11 10 years in i miss my friends
yeah i miss my goddamn friends i hope
they don't die
i hope the store doesn't close
everything was if the store is gone i
was like i'm
moving immediately i'm out of here
because i'm only here for the store
and my friends that's it the friends at
the store that's why i'm here
you know well you know we're back uh
you know it's like the stores that
they're at you know fully vaccinated
shows and that's like a whole thing too
people are you know
people and i can't stand these people
sending their messages about like you
know
just like before like you know just my
only rant would be just
hey take personal responsibility it just
really pisses me off that like
people want to go out they want to spend
money they want to drink
yeah they want to eat they want to like
laugh they want to projectile spit
laugh yeah yeah you know at a place and
then when something happens they want to
blame the building
yeah here's what i do personal
responsibility here's what i do eric
i got a show tonight at four o'clock
i'm gonna covet test and every time i go
to do a show now
i covet test myself because even if
you're fully vaccinated you could still
maybe have it you go in
so i test myself and i go i'm clean
today and i go do the show
that's all you can do i know man and
that's just
who knows i ho hopefully yeah hopefully
this will subside and this will go you
know
it won't be a thing then we can like
really because right now what the tough
part about it is it's like
it's like such a hindrance to like the
good time that this is supposed to be
i get it i get it yeah you know what i
mean it was supposed to be just it's
supposed to be about
uh communal bonding experience that now
has this
kind of like cloud over it and so
hopefully like you know we can all get
healthy or
we can like beat this thing and we can
just like you know i think the worst
thing about it is
besides doctors we're the second people
to help people you know whether it be
a major tragedy in your life of say 9 11
or covet or any of these big
tragedies where we come together and
make people laugh
and we couldn't do it so that was really
[ __ ] bizarre
like we can't help these people through
these dark times
well you know people are see what i you
know you monetize your content in
another way i think that's this podcast
format
is totally because i get a lot of them
all through covet i mean
may you help me get through this dude i
get that i love that when i get this
yeah
i feel so good because as i'm editing an
episode for four hours
and you're so sick of doing it oh yeah
then you put it up and they're like dude
man i got cancer
right i'm at i'm at chemo and i'm
listening to this and i'm laughing and i
feel great and i go that's it
that's that's that's why you do it every
time i feel like i don't want to do it
i'll i'll be out some places somebody
will see me at a store just randomly be
like dude love your podcast yeah
then i go oh you're making me have to
continue this
i remember i was gonna quit at the uh
nine year mark my podcast and i go
this is it i'm just i did it nine years
and i thought about it for a couple
weeks i go i'll just get the number 500
and then i'll be out i did it for 500 it
won't look like a quitter nine years
yeah i get the 500 and i get john mayer
and paul stanley from kiss kiss the
whole reason i'm alive right now yeah
and and john mayer who i absolutely love
you know
and i go oh [ __ ] and about
three months ago i got ac dc my favorite
band of all time their first podcast i
go
god good thing i didn't quit yeah and it
reminded me of what burr said he goes
look you've got a lot of drive and
you're you probably aren't gonna make it
uh but you know you know how you're not
gonna make it
is if you quit yeah you know what i mean
that was his he was
he wasn't saying you're not gonna make
it i know he was saying the way
you're not gonna make it for sure is if
you quit you know
yeah that was funny man well you did it
you didn't quit and you're here now
this is uh mr dean del rey so tell us
give me some new stuff like where are
you gonna be i'll probably put this
episode out this monday oh good
so i'm in new york all this week so uh
every night i'm at the stand and the
cellar and then
friday night i'll be in connecticut with
bill burr at foxwoods casino
and then i'm doing the bird tour so i'm
all over america in the next couple
months
uh hopefully that's good yeah that's
that's i'm glad he's got you out there
yeah um so yeah man thanks for coming on
oh we should have done this a lot sooner
right now that i think about it
oh yeah and we got it we got to do some
shows together again yeah we'll figure
it out
we'll figure it out i got i'll find some
whatever dates if you're free it's all
good i'm in
i'm in yeah just to do it man yeah i
know it's just like and it's like also
like
it's it is different when you're out in
some strange city with someone that you
know
i love it like if we go to portland and
we're just out there roasting the
hippies
yeah just being able to go like hey you
want to go to breakfast you want to go
lunch we can see movies i mean
that's just that's the kind of
camaraderie that we need not some
strange young kid who's like
can i open for you like i don't even
[ __ ] know you you can't run these
bits but
yeah yeah yeah yeah can you help me can
you make me a better comic like
i'm not your dad yeah yeah yeah but dean
thanks for coming on thanks guys um
you so check dean out uh make sure you
check out what's the name the cactus
dot cactusradionnetwork.com it's got all
four shows on there right now so check
that out
all the streaming platforms to let there
be talk dean delray and go check out
dean in new york if you're in the new
york area and you know check out go to
bill burr's website
check out when all the places they'll be
we're doing red rocks
wow oh good and then again if you're in
the la
brea orange county area on the 19th i'll
be one night at the brea improv
and then i'll be in escondido in san
diego area the next day on the 20th at
the grand comedy
club for one night great place to work
out great two shows there
he's a good dude yeah so check me out
there make sure you check that out and
this has been dean del rey
this is riffing with griffin and i will
see you next week
you